[音楽]
ここに1枚の写真があります
何の変哲もない写真に見えるかもしれません
でもすんごい写真なんですよ
たった一度でも相続でもめてしまうと
このような初診は二度と見られなくなることを私はよく知っています
さて
皆さんから
大切なご家族に対して贈ることができる
最後にして最高のギフトは何だと思いますか
私なら円満相続をプレゼントします
相続で失敗すると家族の当たり前ができなくなっていきます
特に冠婚葬祭に現れます
法事は自分たちだけで勝手にやるようになり
をは釜よりもコソコソいくようになります
結婚式は呼ばない年賀状は出さない
同じ血を分けた兄弟なん
でもこれが現実です
亡くなった人の財産をどう分けるかを相続人たちで決める話し合いのことを遺産分割
協議と言います
この遺産分割協議を
相続トラブルの舞台にしちゃうのかそれとも家族が一致団結する舞台にするのか
まさに分かれ道です
円満相続を実現するためには
きちんとした遺言書が一番です
私も日頃から口酸っぱくしてお伝えしています
ただ遺言書と聞くとなんかめんどくさいとが縁起悪いとかって
書かない人が結構多いんですね
データによると
日本人で遺言書を書いて亡くなる人はわずか1割ちょっとに過ぎません
ですからなんと9割近くの家族が遺言書がない状態です
つまりこの会場にいらっしゃる
ほとんどの皆さんに当てはまるわけなんです
ですから遺言書がベストではありますが
遺産分割協議の乗り切り方もお伝えしたいんです
とかく揉めた相続といえば
強欲な相続人がいたりとかすごく財産があったりとか
もともと仲悪かったりとかって想像しがちですが実はそうじゃないんです
普通に仲の良かった家族が雨ちゃってるんです
なぜなのか
人間は
感情や思考に
多面性を持っているデリケートな生き物なんです
たとえ育った環境が同じでも一人一人考え方や性格は違いますしお金に対する価値観も
違います
また同じ一人の人間でも例えば住宅ローン抱えていたり介護や子育て真っ最中の時と
もうそれが終わった時では
相続に対する気持ちも違って当然です
このように相続はいろんな要素が複雑に一気に絡み合うため
たとえ仲が良くても揉めてしまうってことは十分あり得るんです
とにかく
連番相続を実現するためには
遺言書がない場合は
遺産分割協議という危ない橋を無事に渡り切ることが必要です
そのためのコツを私の経験からいくつかお伝えします
まずは競技の場所です
場所は実家にこだわらない
どうしてもですね実家で話し合う人が多いんです
ですけどできたら実感は避けた方が良いです
実家はいわば密室ですから
完全個室な状態です
他人の目を気にしなくて済んじゃいますから
た外交大きな声での遠慮なしにねあの
いろんなことを言いちゃうんですね
で遺産分割協議というのは
普通の回避とは違います
今日は6
腹割ってもうジャンジャ意見を出し合うなんて絶対ダメですよ
間違いだけで地雷踏みます
だからいかに発言しづらい
すなわち遠慮したくなる空気を作ることが大事なんです
そのためには他人の目があったらいいんです
ですが完全個室というより半個室ぐらいがちょうどいいんです
具体的にお勧めしてみましょう
ちょっと離れたファミレスあ
えっ
ここはうってつけですよ立ってホールスタッフの人の目や隣の席の人の目
ねあんなところで大きな声出せます
もっとおすすめしたい場所
うなぎ屋さんです
2070い引用しますでしょ
あれがいいんですよ
で競技を始める時間が大事です
午前11時スタート
そこそこねお腹がすいてくる時間がいいんです
で始めるときの殺し文句があります
終わったらご飯にしますから
ハッハー
いやね本当にね
もう協議中でプンプンによってくるわけですよ
いや小高もブームになってくるそりゃもうちゃっちゃと競技なんか済ましちゃってはい
を食べたいじゃないですか
こういう空気をつくった第3です
して次は競技に参加するメンバーについてです
相続人じゃない家族は参加しない
はいみなさん
突然ですがここでエクササイズの時間ですさあ皆さん左手を出してもらっていいですか
入っ手のひらを上に上げていただいて
右手で
はいこのように
おいてください右手をねこのめんはい
じゃあ2回ありますので今からエクササイズを一緒についていてください
じゃあ行きます3杯1234
はい今ですごい大事なことやりましたんでねあのちょっと覚えてくださいね
あれは2年前のことです
父親を亡くして遺産分割協議を翌日に控えたある男性が夫婦で相談にみえました
で相談だ終わって帰りしなに私は奥様に念のため伝えました
奥様
明日の協議は相続人だけで行いませんで
艶楼してもらえますか
なんで
家の人心配だから私が参加しなくてどうするの
結構の生きようと言われました
は当日です
会場に着いてみると
安農場相続人でもない奥様が一番乗りでした
そして席の中央に貼付させました
競技が始まってももう身振り手振りでハッスルハッスル
あのマンマンショーでしたこれじゃあまとまるわけありません
2年たった今も
土地の名義がいところか預貯金の1円も下ろせないままの
持ちブライン状態です
そうかと思えば別の事例です
同じように
ある男性が父親を亡くして奥さんと一緒に相談に行きました
9割5分
しゃべるのは相続人じゃない奥様の方でした
そして帰り車私私はまた伝えました奥様
明日の協議は相続人だけでございますので参加はご遠慮ください
あっ範囲
わかりました
なんかとって気のない返事でしたさ
さあ当日です
集まった相続人の中に磯の奥様はいませんでしたので私はちょっとホッとしていました
そして競技が始まろうとしたまさにその時です
とんとんノックの音です
やっぱりその奥さんでした
まあなんだよやっぱりくるのか
私が内心ガッカリするなか奥様がお茶を持って入ってきました
しかしです
お茶を配り終わるやいなやよ
失礼します
部屋を出てきました
それから競技が終わるまでの小一時間
一切入ってきませんでした車
この見事ですねー
もちろん競技も無事終わりました
この2つの係数どちらも相続人同士仲良かったんですね
でも一方はも右手1本は揉めなかった
これ決して偶然じゃないです
これは私の経験上性別が入れ替わっても全く同じです
最初の印象が大事なんです
相続人と一緒に来る加速=
応援団誰だってそう思いますよね
その応援団が主役のように真ん中に席にでんと座ってたら
ファイティングポーズとってるという人じゃないですか
そりゃ相手だってファイティングポーズ取りますよ
方やお茶だけだして出演しますって弾き込んだら
あえてどう思う
気前てるなぁ
この違いが大きいんですね
はいみなさんということでもう一度あの f サイズ
はいやってましょうねはいそれでははい左手はこういうふうに上げて右ておこうですね
はいじゃあ3回行きましょうかね3杯123
お茶出して失礼します
はいもうこれでね皆さん大丈夫ですか
はい
荒れます
はい次はですね
競技に参加する皆さんの心構えです
期待しすぎない
競技ですねどうしてもですねあのー
バラ色の結果だけを
をもっと参加するとか結構います私はそう言うとにはですねこう伝えています
ギリギリだけをできる最低ラインの結果もカテゴして参加してください
遺産分割協議を翌日に控えたある男性に私は聞きました
あなたにとって腹 l の結果は何ですか
俺が全部相続することだ
あ
じゃあのギリギリ妥協できる最低ラインの結果は
では同じだよ
全部俺が想像することや
だってアイツが相続するなんてありえないよ
あんだけ迷惑かけておいて
でもこれじゃあ結果は見えています案の定
法定相続分を要求され彼はパニックになりました
私はその時の彼の取り乱した猪狩の声を忘れることができません
いまだに裁判所で調停やってます
人間バラ色の結果だけを期待しているとそれ以外の結果はショックで受け入れられない
もんなんですね
さあ昨年11月30日
私の誕生日のことです私は仕事を終え家路に急ぐ中
私が家に着いたときの家族のリアクションこれを20理想像しました
まずはバラ色のリアクションです
私は玄関の扉を開けた瞬間クラッカーの音がパーンパーン
パパ誕生日おめで所
子どもたちが抱きついてきます
そしてライニングに行くとカミさんが用意した豪華な料理と大きなホールケーキ
部屋中には飾り付けがしてありハピバースデーの大合唱が始まります
今度一方ギリギリ妥協できる最低ラインのリアクションです
呼び鈴を何度も鳴らしても全然出てきませんので
自分で鍵をさせてあげます
そーっと暗い部屋に入っていくと
テーブルの隅っこに何かコンビニで買ったような
ちっちゃな松涛ケーキがポツンと置いたいます
そその横にレシートの裏に書かれた
パパ誕生かめでとうはって一緒
走り書きが書いてあります
これがで私がギリギリだけができる最低ラインのリアクションですよね
ずいぶん半割りませんでしょ
でもねこれぐらいあってもいいんですえっ
ちなみに実際の結果ですけどあのバラ色とまでは行かなかったですけど
まあそれはそれなりにあの十分嬉しいリアクションでした
もし僕がねあの時にバレーの結果だけを期待していたらガッカリするどころか行かれて
自分でね自分の誕生日を台無しにしてたかもしれません
とにかくですねあまり期待はしすぎないように
自分が受け入れる幅はね広く持って
回競技には参加してください
そして最後のコツです
持ち帰らせない
無事ですね協議がまとまりましたら遺産分割協議書というのに署名捺印が必要なんです
がこれは必ずその場で一発で決めてください
まごまごしていると伊月が変わるか分かりません
一旦ゆっくり家に持ち帰って考えたいわなんてことになったらもう周りから知恵をつけ
られてアウトです
せっかくね同意してたのに
家に持ち帰ったね本当に出来が変わるからね怖いんですね
ですから必ず実印と印鑑証明書んね用意したと思いください
電話でまず事前交渉しておいてそれでまとまりそうなら
実印と印鑑証明証を必ず当日で持ってきてよって言ってください
このよう
生かしてなかったばっかりに
競技を後日に持ち越して気が変わっても目ちゃったなんていくらでもあるんです
さあここまで遺産分割協議を無事に乗り切るコツをお伝えしてきましたがどれも
法的知識なんていらないんです
もめないように話し合いができる関係を作っているだけですから
でもこれが大事なんです
えん間に終わった相続はこの環境づくりが効いてたんです
しかもこの環境づくりは専門家じゃなくてもだれにでもそう皆さんでもできることなん
です
財産分けの話がですね星まとまりましたらまずは一安心です
ただこれで終わりにしたら私がプレゼントしたい本当の円満相続ではありません
相続は財産分けのためだけにあるわけじゃないんですね
大切な家族を失ってぐらついている家族の絆をもう一度結びなおすためにあるんです
どうか明日への一致団結を家族全員で誓って宣言してください
例えば
盆正月は必ず実家に帰って
みんなでは構えるに行く
あるいは
兄弟同士これからも仲良くして困ったときはお互いに助け合う
お母さんの老後の世話は子どもたちみんなで協力する
必ず紙に書いて相続人全員で読み上げてください
そうやって家族の絆をねみんなで確認して心に刻むんです
最愛の家族を失った時だからこそより一層強く
これからも協力しあって生きていけるように
みんな仲良くいつものしていられるように
それこそが本当の円満相続
そして家族への最後にして最高のギフトになるんです
ありがとうございましたん
[拍手]